what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and the mha manga just
keeps getting darker and more brutal in
this final arc the number one pro hero
is sacrificing his life right in front
of us in a battle to the death
all for one is now eating people's souls
or something and what is happening with
deku events are moving quickly the story
is intense so let's talk about it right
now
you guys know how this works if you
enjoy our videos and you want to see
more just leave a quick like and comment
it costs you nothing and it takes you
only a second but it helps us out a lot
and of course if you want to see more
videos in the future just click
subscribe and hit that bell and you're
set finally this video will contain mha
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned okay so
remember how two chapters ago i said in
a video that endeavour's right arm had
been ripped off by all for one and then
in my video on the previous chapter i
had to correct myself because it turned
out that endeavour's arm was fine he was
just injured in the area below his right
armpit well about that
but more on that later the latest
chapter starts off with giro tokuyami
and hawks still facing off against all
for one and all for one is still being
weakened by his own quirks rebelling
against him on the inside in the
previous chapter we saw that all for
one's mask had been partially destroyed
and in this chapter tokuyami uses an
attack with like the most emo name ever
to smash all for one in the face with
dark shadow and destroy the rest of his
mask but even with the mask destroyed
the heroes continue to attack all for
one relentlessly hawks proclaims that
they are not just trying to buy time
until endeavour recovers and is able to
join the fight again despite the fact
that they are not as strong as endeavor
hawks tokyami and jiro are going all out
and they're doing their best to defeat
all for one before he can do any more
damage for his part all for one is
surprised that he wasn't able to easily
dodge these attacks even after losing
his hearing and eyesight to the severe
injuries he sustained during his first
battle with all might he still had
superior senses to normal humans because
he was able to use multiple sensory
quirks including infrared vision
detecting vibrations and so on but now
all of these quirks that he relied on
are rebelling against him from the
inside and this is really slowing him
down and making him weaker in this
crucial moment also this has never
happened to of one before and he still
hasn't figured out why exactly these
consciousnesses or vestiges inside of
him which he refers to as fragile
reproductions are able to fight back
against him all for one then proceeds to
attack the rebellious quirks inside of
him and he appears to be eating the
vestiges almost like he is devouring the
souls of the former users he looks like
he's about to eat the white-haired woman
that we saw in the previous chapter and
then before hawks can deliver the
finishing blow an explosion of rivet
stabs emerges from all for one's body
the rivets are able to protect all for
one while injuring hawks and they also
seem to be repairing all for one's mask
by gathering up all the broken pieces
and putting them back together at least
that's what it looked like to me based
on the panels for a moment it appears as
if hawks tokyoami and jiro are about to
be turned into swiss cheese by all these
rivets but that is when endeavour
arrives to save the day he puts his own
body between hawks and the rivets and he
begins smashing the rivets with his
fists however some of the rivets pierce
through his right hand and eventually
his right arm is torn off just above the
elbow as a fierce and furious endeavor
rushes at all for one so yeah if anyone
tells you that i was wrong about
endeavour getting his right arm ripped
off two chapters ago you can tell him
that i wasn't wrong i was just using
future sight the chapter then gives us a
break from all that insane action in
order to reveal some of endeavour's
backstory including the story of how he
really decided to become the hero he is
today back when ng todoroki was a boy
around high school age he witnessed a
father desperately trying to save his
daughter from a villain but the father
failed and both he and the daughter were
brutally killed by the villain right in
front of angie in that moment angie
understood firsthand just how much
better all might is compared to ordinary
people almight was out there fighting
villains like this every single day and
yet for an ordinary human one wrong move
and they could be killed in an instant
angie felt intense feelings of
inferiority and even jealousy towards
all might in this moment and that's when
he decided to make his hero name
endeavor the name represents angie's
determination to work hard and keep
striving until he one day surpasses even
almight himself and in this moment back
in the present time endeavour finally
realizes the truth he will never be like
all might or deku and he was never
really fighting to surpass all might
anyway all this time endeavor has been
fighting against himself against his own
weakness and sense of powerlessness
when he witnessed the death of that
father and daughter at the hands of a
villain he felt weak and powerless and
all this time he has been fighting to
escape that feeling he has been fighting
to outrun his own weakness
his giant ego his obsession with all
might his abusive behavior towards shoto
and the rest of his family none of that
was really about becoming the number one
pro hero or about becoming the strongest
for his entire life endeavor has been
driven by his sense of weakness and his
desperate desire to overcome it it is
not the pursuit of strength in itself
that he has been living for but the fear
of his own weakness
and now finally endeavour seems to
understand instead of cursing his
weakness he embraces it and he launches
an all-out attack at all for one he uses
his quirk to generate a new hand made of
flames in the place of his old one and
he unleashes the full force of his
attack into all for one's body as all
for one falls back under the force of
endeavors flames angie todoroki declares
that ending this fight once and for all
is his duty and that is how this chapter
ends
wow we are witnessing such incredible
character progression from endeavor when
he was first introduced in the story he
came off as this narcissistic egomaniac
who just wanted to become the strongest
hero in the world in order to satisfy
his own petty ego and yet
that was only scratching the surface of
his character we now know that
endeavour's obsession with becoming the
strongest and surpassing all might
didn't come from just a petty desire to
be the best instead it came from a
deeply ingrained childhood trauma angie
witnessed a horrific crime and he felt
powerless to do anything as two people
were brutally slain right in front of
him that feeling of weakness and
helplessness horrified him and he never
wanted to feel that way again
so he got it into his head that he had
to become the number one pro hero and
that he had to surpass all might at all
costs but not so that he could brag
about it and bask in his own glory angie
felt that he had to do this just so he
could stop being afraid and he thought
that the only way to overcome his
feelings of fear and inadequacy was to
become the strongest or to raise his son
to become the strongest if we look deep
enough beneath the surface we realized
that angie didn't do what he did because
he was cocky or competitive in reality
he did it because he was scared and
becoming the strongest was the only way
for angie to convince himself that he
doesn't need to be afraid anymore now
none of that excuses the bad things that
he willingly chose to do but this does
tell us where it all started and how
angie became the man he is today i
honestly think that endeavor is the best
written character in mha at this point
in time he is a deeply flawed
multifaceted character and he just feels
like a fully fleshed out imperfect human
being honestly kudos to horikoshi for
giving this man a phenomenal character
arc drop me a line down in the comments
with your thoughts on endeavour's
character do you agree with me that he
is the best written character in the
story or do you just hate him because of
the bad things he's done in the past we
also need to talk about all for one's
apparent ability to just like consume
the vestiges that were rebelling against
him i mean is it really going to be that
easy after placing all of that emphasis
on the fact that something like this has
never happened to all for one before is
horikoshi really just gonna be like okay
he's back to normal now he just ate the
souls of the other users no big deal
honestly i'm not sure what's gonna
happen but i do feel that that
white-haired woman may end up being
important in the future i could be
totally wrong on this but we'll have to
wait and see nevertheless if all for one
really can somehow consume the vestiges
and neutralize them completely then we
have to think about the massive
implications that this could have for
deku and one for all i mean what if all
for one finds a way to consume the
vestiges of one for all which would
neutralize them and clear the way for
one for all to finally be stolen all for
one defeating his own rebellious
vestiges was just like a quick creepy
scene but we can't underestimate the
potentially massive consequences of this
reveal for the final battle between
shigaraki and deku definitely let me
know what you guys thought of this and
do you think that all for one consuming
the vestiges foreshadows the possibility
of all for one consuming the vestiges
within one for all also why haven't we
seen deku in almost three months i think
the last time we saw him was chapter 349
so like seven chapters ago
with this being the final arc and
everything you would think that the main
character would get more screen time i
know a lot of people have been saying
that horikoshi is rushing the mha manga
but i really don't think that's true
if he was rushing then he could have
just gone right to the main battle
between deku and shigaraki and
everything else could have just been
shown in quick bursts during that final
battle or it could even happen
off-screen the way that horikoshi is
structuring this war arc and the way he
has sidelined deku over the past few
months tells me that he isn't really
rushing he is clearly moving at the pace
he's comfortable with and he's taking
his time with the side battles before
getting to the main event do you guys
agree let me know down below as always
if you enjoyed the video and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment it only takes you a
second but it helps me out a lot and of
course subscribing and hitting that bell
is a completely free way of directly
supporting this channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime outpour patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to kyle salisbury this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twigo himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including alpha sigma pate
heffa the red-haired fox hinokami and
water the toasted chi corey mcgowan the
fallen chosen orihime wukong dante
tinnell and big buddhist finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh on
hell cruz alicia octor bonnie parks fat
boy games kaido might be a duck alivania
and anime s codem if you guys enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys